[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais je suis allé faire un saut du coup
sur canal+ ici la famille j'ai maté
l'effet papillon l'effet papillon il
avait surgi sur la chirurgie esthétique
dans laquelle je sortais des micros
regarder dans la gueule du chanteur
témoigne de façon anonyme regardez
aujourd'hui cette jeune chanteuse de 19
ans qui veut rester anonyme vient pour
une visite de contrôle
ils écrivent son nom en grand sur
l'écran ou bien sûr c'est lourd
[Applaudissements]
j'viens de la synagogue ont la garde si
l'on vous savez qui c'est ça on sait qui
c'est ça ouais ouais presque pas pour
jean pierre foucault en tout cas elles
découvrent que leur idole
nicky me jackson connaissait merci il
est bien seul sur le côté
à léogâne vous pouvez bien qu'elle ait
demandé tout s'arrangerait pas mal de
monde surtout les téléspectateurs dacia
vous bonjour talk show elle découvre que
leur idole
nicky me jaak vous connaissez bien
[Applaudissements]
rapidement quand même subi